merci madame la ministre la parole les
cas madame valérie pécresse
ma question
ma question s'adresse au premier
ministre vendredi dernier le terrorisme
islamiste aveugle et barbare a de
nouveau frappé notre pays je veux à mon
tour avoir une pensée émue et
chaleureuse pour les victimes et leurs
proches et rendre hommage au dévouement
des forces de sécurité et de secours
aujourd'hui l'unité nationale exige
l'action nous devons construire un
bouclier de sécurité pour protéger les
français
je souhaite vous parler plus
particulièrement des réseaux de
transport qu'ils sont nous le savons
tous des points de vulnérabilité face à
la menace terroriste
nous avons appris avec satisfaction le
renforcement des moyens civils et
militaires dans les gares et sur les
réseaux néanmoins ce matin lors de
l'audition des présidents de la sncf et
de la ratp des réseaux de bus il est
apparu qu'il fallait aller beaucoup plus
loin pour renforcer la sécurité dans nos
transports je vous fait quatre
propositions je vous propose à nouveau
comme l'on demandait la sncf le
groupement des autorités responsables
des transports depuis janvier dernier le
port obligatoire de la carte d'identité
dans les transports publics pour
faciliter le travail des forces de
sécurité je vous propose pour éviter les
inégalités en matière de sécurité entre
les français qui serait intolérable de
créer des polices de transport dans
chaque région compétente pour tous les
transports ferroviaires métrobus y
compris les transports scolaires
je vous propose généraliser la
vidéoprotection et d'installer des
portiques de sécurité de contrôle des
bagages sur les grandes lignes les
lignes internationales et dans les
grandes gares
je vous propose enfin d'instaurer un
régime de partage d'informations entre
les services de renseignement et tous
les services publics visant à leur
signer
leurs employés fichier est ce dangereux
pour les avertir leur permettent
d'empêcher le recrutement ou de les
licencier un fish est radicalisée ne
doit pas pouvoir conduire un train rer
ou à métro pouvons-nous la parole et à
monsieur bernard cazeneuve ministre de
l'intérieur madame la députée vous
proposer un certain nombre
d'orientations qui ont été évoqués dans
le cas de la réunion du comité national
de la sécurité dans les transports en
commun qui avait été créé en 2011 et qui
s'est réuni pour la première fois en
2013 alors que ni le mr valls était
ministre de l'intérieur pour prendre un
certain nombre de dispositions ce que la
sécurité des transports en commun
rassemble l'ensemble des grands
présidents des organismes de transport
qui ont fait effectivement madame
pécresse des propositions que vous avez
relayé de façon très fidèle et qui
correspond très exactement au sujet dont
on traite ensemble et qui ont vocation à
aboutir dans les prochains mois pour un
certain nombre d'entre elles
je vais reprendre ses propres pions
d'abord vous parlez madame la députée
valérie pécresse de la nécessité de
cribler davantage les personnes qui
travaillent dans les entreprises de
transports en commun cela existe pour un
certain nombre de professions en france
si si ça existe par exemple pour les
employés des centrales nucléaires ou
d'un certain nombre de sites sensibles
il est donc possible dans le cadre de la
constitution d'étendre aux réseaux de
transport
ces dispositions nous l'avons envisagée
avec les sociétés transport en commun
nous sommes donc tout à fait prêt à le
faire deuxièmement vous proposez que on
renforce la sécurité dans les grandes
gares c'est ce que nous avons fait en
augmentant très significativement les
effectifs des forces de sécurité dans
les gares et nous avons visité commise
la défense et le premier ministre
les dispositifs que nous avons mis en
place nous avons par ailleurs renforcer
la présence qui n'était pas effective
puisque ça n'existait pas de brigade
multinationale dans les trains
transfrontaliers de manière à procéder à
des contrôles dans les trains dans les
trains des contrôles d'identité de faire
sonner les fiches lorsque il y a des
fiches et de pouvoir procéder aux
arrestations de ceux qui doivent l'être
vous posez la création de forces de
sécurité supplémentaires pour les
transports en commun c'est exactement ce
que nous faisons grâce aux postes les
raisons dans la banlieue